us when Michelson goes that far under par he's in
good shape Morgan riy moves in shoots and that's
squeezed here's Nick Robertson in the Toronto
lineup some late adjustments du to illness for
the leaves as doy works that back L going to shot
it went up a leg in front that's been brought up
a time or two mhm DJ BR goes back and hurdle
steps into himash hurdle trying to work that
free does steps on and shoots Jones makes the
save that a former New Jersey Delo came over
in the Teo Meer trade the Sharks got a batlo
for that lead pass now for bzi walking right
in backand shot stopped in tight by kako heads
off opens up the seam bzi hits it perfectly and
it's set in alone now the forb drag move is
hard to execute when you're get chased cuz
you you got to go laterally so much you're going
to get caught and kin was able to stay with the
puck long enough now trying to pull that free
on comes Matthews on L change Marr looks back
to him he kicks it down still loose he Shields
at the goal post the white tape Austin Matthews
comes this close to getting the opener back the
BR shoots at the goal post toar throws it back
and front that just missed here's Riley back with
it play that back Bry shot go off a leg right to
nander nander pulls it back for Ry walks and
shoots scor for and Ry on the Fe from neander
and the leaves take a one nothing [Music] lead
nice activation by Morgan Riley nean walks up and
Riley walks down and they catch Zin looking at the
puck and not at the 20 Zin Riley's his guy he's
got to slide back underneath he gets chased Land
by the blue line that's not a good idea and then
fori in front taking care of Ferraro so Morgan
Riley can take care of the [Music] goaler slid
it across to tarus back for neander down to Riley
Tander has a look feeds across the Matthews Taps
it back and shoot [Applause] SC against Dan Jose
how about the angle they work into the bumper to
Mar he has a shot threat but m Matthews then fls
back out deeper he's got his bottom skate on the
circle and look at the angle just pops it to
the top of the net perfect pass Marty Matthew's
great chemistry together and that is a that's not
banked off the shoulder that's just underneath the
bar th erson lost the bucket Center ice and marer
quickly head for KN Matthew KN in shoot and a pad
save by K Matthews back for L Rossi goes to McCade
chopped on goal they score what a deflection
by Mar on the shot by mccab and it's three to
[Applause] [Music] nothing what a sweet tip way
wide more offensive own possession Marner flows
by himself FR trying to get over there but that
is really well done to create the angle but also
to get it in the air and rattle around the hands
of cochan in to slide in behind him oh perfect
that is really nice from Mitch mner got a B off
back moves it back to McMahon for
he's W up Hallberg Tri a go score
oh one hander how about that it's four nothing
P this homberg with his first goal in 19 games
you'd never know it Ben W Feed his guy up the
ice you're thinking okay what homberg could take
the soft chip and just shovel in front of that
one handed but he gets Burrows on his back in
that is nice the strength get the leg out and
again to elevate it over the pad of cocken by
homberg is beauty rolls it and flicks it and
makes it four nothing yeah MIT Mar has all our
reactions hello in for declair back for granin
mik granin spins back in the corner drops that
back to declair for granin senters a tip score
and Henry Thun gets his first National Hockey
League goal on the deflection in front for a
power play marker that gets a tire group of
penalty Killers out there and run who sort
of played on the blue line slid to the bumper
position don't think he's supposed to be down
there takes a nice pass from grin and just opens
it up sadine slap pass tip it up top and right
off the bar and in like he's n of a four which
he had not bed by Anaheim in the fourth round in
2019 was traded to San Jose for a third round
pick he won a gold medal with the US and Marr
shuffel out rink wide for do shortens up plays
it for Riley across the Matthews a hard drive
and Blackwood stops that always working to space
where he can do this DOI back to macave again for
DOI Robertson fighting for space take it all
the way M walks right in little backand shot
at the goal post Jake mcabe dangling there a
knee Lander to Jord ad beats it across to L
sends it back in bouncing pu black but makes the
saving tight holds it long enough as taros was
trying to dig that free and then everything
rolled on their Bar B off gets stuck in the
middle and now it breaks down the defensive
Zone coverage you can say what you want about
not being able to score goals and that's
a function of talent and there's not a lot
sometimes Rockwood in comes Mar feeds it across
M the CH scor Jake McCain makes it five to one
and win the face off rotate over Martin takes the
open ice and then how about this declair is drawn
in to Matthews thinking about a onetime declair
right on his backside who's his defenseman Mame
now not everyone can see him and even fewer can
make that pass and now we're going to need repairs
because thank you very much M BLS up the net cam
with the center Shot back at the top for nander
down to Matthews back to neander Riley sends it
back and score Miner punch at home now alone in
seventh place on the L's alltime Point L he moves
past the Big M Frank Mage looks pretty good Morgan
Riley getting to the back door he do a great job
drawing guys in and then getting it to on the
tape and Morgan Riley is his good game gets it to
Marner stick of the tips have been nice for Mitch
Marner hardly ever first one a pretty good save
but easy tap in and that would be M Robertson do
it broken oh there's another high stick there
almost by C Riley drops it back M hamers that
wide now Robertson shoot
scores ni Robert back of the lineup goes to
the back of the net and it's s to one a means
very little in this game it means a lot to Nick
Robertson he needs offense he needs confidence
he needs to be able to to score goals like
this this is what he does it's what he's
supposed to do it's what he can do and a lot
of it confidence some of his opportunity he
just rips that one five hole rud plays that
back front for zerland back to rud centering
pass great stop there by Jones nice save and
bruzi gets caught in between and what a save
gets across gets flat leaves the stick behind
him if he has to Tron didn't hit the target he
was looking for maybe pulled it a little too
far back towards the center of the net but
still that long shot knocked away two
blocks to end the game to [Music] see